Коли Ерік Фріск приходить додому,
йому не потрібен ключ. Вхідні двері можна відкрити
електронним способом. При цьому йому не потрібна
магнітна картка чи навіть відбиток пальця.
Таємний ключ в нього ось тут: між великим і
вказівним пальцями його лівої руки.
Це малесенький мікрочіп, трохи менший
двох сантиметрів, який Ерік імплантував під шкіру.
Його дівчину нещодавно теж "прочіпували",
як кажуть шведи. Тож нині вони можуть не лише
відчиняти вхідні двері, але й, приміром,
у такий спосіб надавати для контролю квитки
на поїзд. І це лише початок.
- Цікаво буде, коли чіпи стануть іще розумнішими.
Тоді ви зможете не тільки відкривати двері.
Чіпи могли б постійно звітувати про мою
температуру тіла або рівень цукру в крові і так далі,
щоб контролювати моє тіло.
Стокгольмське метро збирається незабаром
відкрити свої турнікети для пасажирів
із імплантованими чіпами. Понад 3,5 тисячі шведів
уже носять їх під шкірою. Передусім молоді люди,
за даними опитувань, швидко надихаються
цифровими винаходами. Побоювання щодо
зловживань їхніми персональними даними -
рідкість. У Швеції висока довіра до держави та влади.
А так звані "вечірки чіпованих" - найновіший тренд
у Стокгольмі. Між келихами вина вам можуть
імплантувати чіп під шкіру. Операція коштує
близько 150 євро. Не болючіше, ніж пірсинг вуха,
запевняють ті, хто це вже зробив і бачать у цьому
лише переваги.
- Мені нема чого приховувати. Я активний
у соцмережах, у мене є своя компанія.
Мене все одно можна швидко відстежити,
тож у мене немає страху щодо цього.
- Усе стає непотрібним. Замість того, щоб мати
кредитні картки та мобільні телефони, незабаром я
носитиму все це під шкірою.
Утім, не скрізь у Європі цим так захоплюються.
Дослідження ЄС попереджає про ризики
імплантування мікрочіпів. З їх допомогою можна
легко створювати профілі руху та впливати
на поведінку людей. У Шведській службі
захисту даних теж застерігають.
- Із точки зору конфіденційності завжди існують
ризики, пов'язані з використанням
персональної інформації. І це залежить від того,
як ви захищаєте свої дані. Тож вам слід провести
аналіз ризиків, перш ніж використовувати ці чіпи.
Аналіз ризиків більше не потрібен продавцю чіпів
Йовану Остерлунду. Цей тренд неможливо зупинити
Незабаром чіпи будуть не тільки носити в руці,
але й у голові.
Через 30 років відбудеться чіткий розподіл
суспільства між природними та неприродними
громадянами. Природні продовжуватимуть
відкидати будь-яку технічну оптимізацію свого тіла.
Це як відмова від медичного страхування сьогодні.
Ерік Фріск та його подруга обрали
цифрову оптимізацію. У медицині технічні засоби
вже давно імплантуються в організм.
Подумайте про кардіостимулятор.
Це доволі серйозне втручання! Я думаю, що ми
просто хочемо ставати здоровішими і міцнішими.
Ось чому я хотів би спробувати ще й багато іншого,
якщо ця технологія вже достатньо зріла.
Маленький чіп у вашій руці - це лише початок,
і не лише для цієї молодої пари.
"Чіпованих" шведів щодня стає дедалі більше.